[Music]
shame on you trouble when you walked in
Taylor Swift some police departments are
trying new methods to catch criminals
known as porch pirates is what they call
them these alleged thieves sneak into
yards and steal packages left on
doorsteps reports show at least 23
million Americans have fallen victim to
the crime and some officers are now
turning to technology for help but
critics say that raises privacy concerns
Mireya Villarreal is on a porch a
real-life porch near Los Angeles Maria
good morning good morning these mounted
security cameras can catch the crime and
sometimes the criminal but that doesn't
always happen that's why police are
making their own deliveries using bait
packages with GPS trackers inside so
they can find the thief and arrest him
in Pittsburgh Houston and Los Angeles
these alleged porch pirates are quick
and brazen in Campbell California home
owner Terry Bolin security cameras
caught this man approaching his porch
before apparently making off with his
delivery it's one of those things in
life you just don't need to go through
that motivated him to work with his
local police department who now uses his
porch to drop off bait packages hoping
to lure criminals inside a regular
shipping box officers pack a common
delivery item along with a GPS tracking
device they want to keep that under
wraps so criminals don't know what to
look for we found that a lot of times
these thieves are opening up the boxes
before they even leave to make sure it's
something that they want so these these
are actually getting picky they are
getting picky the programs have been a
success in several cities across the
country in Southern California Arcadia
police say more than a hundred suspected
thieves have taken the bait but the
tactic also raised concerns after a
stolen bait package led to a high speed
chase and officers swarming a movie
theater to make an arrest while experts
say these operations are legal some say
they should be regulated by court order
or warrant citizens absolutely should be
concerned about tracking technologies
and law enforcement unfettered access to
tracking technologies another concern
some departments deliberately putting
higher price items in the bait packages
which could result in a felony
conviction bumping up the value of
what's in the boxes could raise some
concerns from the point of view of
fairness and due process there are
critics out there that will say you are
trying to trap these thieves into a
bigger crime is that what's happening
here this is about us identifying a
trend that's happening not only in
Campbell but throughout the country and
it's really a way for us to work with
our community it's a sentiment shared by
many homeowners I feel all for the
program it should feel safe and
comfortable now in your home but in your
neighborhood to avoid being a victim
police say have your packages delivered
somewhere where someone can receive them
in person so maybe your work or a
neighbor's home they also suggest
installing security cameras like this
ring doorbell that way you can deter
thieves altogether an important reminder
of cameras everywhere Mariah thank you